[Music]
two
please give a warm welcome to the host
of the 2023 steamy Awards Ethan Clark
hello everybody and welcome to the most
important event of the year we are of
course talking about the steamies it is
2022 steamies I hate to correct our
esteemed announcer back there
thank you but you know what uh it is
what it is right folks today we are
joined by
two very special co-hosts today joined
by Tana as everybody knows her nobody
really knows how to say her last name
don't say Mojo
it's what it's wittic today it's wittic
oh don't do that don't you're not in a
relationship
and of course uh Tana's significant
other Jeff is here
I'm happy to be here this is uh this is
gonna be a historical night tonight it
will go down in YouTube history do you
know that Ethan is in the midst of
controversy
criticized for his actions yeah we will
not hustle we will we said don't mention
that we will we will show started Carrie
and we will critique these pieces of
[__] that are we both are nominated we
are nominated we are also pieces of [__]
yeah so I'm I'm going to so guys I
welcome you all and hope you have a
blessed evening here today we of course
the steamies is here in defiance to the
Streamys which is the most corrupt
institution in [__] entertainment
today they are scum they're dishonest
and their categories as rigged as [__]
five times for best podcast and I keep
being beaten by like Jay Shetty who the
[__] even is that do you know who JJ is
they got a really good podcast actually
you like his podcast uh I mean I I never
watch how do you know I just saw you had
Kendall Jenner on and some clickbait
stuff that he did but sure wow sounds
really good Jeff anyway I've won a
streamy award before so guys this is
Ethan's opinion honestly same that's how
we know it's right well listen by being
here
of the year I know proves his point
which is super weird right what's up a
million trees and all I did was suck
dick and smoke weeds yeah well let's not
discount those achievements right
seriously I worked really hard at that I
appreciate that yeah and um well guys uh
without further Ado let's get right into
it welcome everybody
every single person here is being paid
to clap on every my team too they're the
election
[Music]
oh thank you so much you both look very
good thank you uh we are on nipple watch
on Tana's top there I know I keep having
nip slips which is so embarrassing he
told me in front of my wife explicitly
can you keep your eye on my nipples well
not can you keep your eye on my nip more
so just like let's not get banned from
Tick Tock okay I understand but it is my
fault I think I kind of disassociate the
sexualization of nipples I kind of think
about it as like my elbow okay which is
interesting it's a nipple well would you
ever consider wearing pasties under a
top like that I don't know that the
mechanics of such things no not this no
there's enough fabric you know what I
mean yeah yeah yeah it's hard as is I'd
like to take a moment to give a shout
out to a B for Lending me his bow tie it
was very nice of him to do it he's a
good man good man yeah I do want to say
though you both are explicitly
denouncing the streaming by being here I
just want to make that uh known so good
to know just establishing that effect
right out the gate well we have so many
huge nominees I am am buzzing with
excitement I could not sleep last night
and I just thank you both for being here
uh you guys are our terrific partner for
this event and I thank you both so much
from the bottom of my heart you're
really the only award show that would
have us so we're good yeah thank you for
thinking to us the word on the street is
I don't know if I'm even able to say it
but they are calling us the new
right in front of me is what they're
saying why can't you stay a friend of me
I don't know is it like agreeable to
speak it over here you and I no they're
saying sort of us oh you guys are the
new friend because she's the the blonde
bimbo and the the he's so sweet we'll
make a move on here you know well
there's more sexual tension between no
no no no no no I yeah I'm celibate she
hasn't just said you suck dick all year
she's in a relate and you're in a
relationship with someone else why don't
you just say that part
well you guys are like friends you guys
are like
Frenemies
sexual tension I don't agree with that
but whatever let's get on with the show
well we this year we received over a
hundred and seven thousand votes my
friends and unlike the Streamys the most
corrupt institution in entertainment
today this is all voted on by the people
for the people there's no shadowy back
room saying like oh Tana one Crater of
the year how did that happen no offense
to you I'll just I was saying that on
stage yeah what's the deal with that the
streamies they just decide in the in the
background YouTube well that's all the
words oh Jay shetty's handsome he's got
nice eyes let's give it kick me back I
don't [__] know he's got crazy ass
Facebook money he kicks back he's
corrupt too he paid him off Jay Shetty
they said he paid them yeah my vape yeah
you can wow this show is not about who's
got the most money it's about who
deserves the award and and one thing I
will say is that do we have voter
protection on these you can only vote
once right Dan
sure and luckily not enough people watch
this where we can confirm that there's
not what's involved they call them dumps
107 000 people care well those are real
votes by real people and that's where we
are and I'll tell you something else the
stream the Streamys would not allow you
to Vape on stage I guarantee it and
that's why they're scum and I've always
said that I've always [__] said that
well let's go over last year's winners
just to kind of um jog our memory
because a lot has changed uh from last
year last year was we were in the depths
of covid business for example biggest
covidia was a category Joe Rogan won
that one handily oh okay yeah was I
nominated you probably were nominated
but I don't remember
why did Joe Rogan so it's a good what
did he do is it a good thing to win no
it's a bad thing for the most part you
don't want to win any of these Awards
then why did I have my entire team vote
for me on repeat all night that was nice
well
well when yours is actually one of the
only good ones you're nominated tonight
for uh Redemption Arc aren't I nominated
well you guys are both nominated for the
good category the one good category what
is it what do I know best Redemption Arc
what's my Redemption Arc I don't well
I'm assuming just
well I didn't think we were oh maybe
maybe because we had um
we squashed the beef together oh so
would you say there was almost a little
bit of like favoritism in this
nomination which would then in fact make
the steamies a bit corrupt it's not
corrupt it's well if people sway one way
or the other that's not corruption Tana
I really don't know what I'm saying I
disassociate it I'll take the frequency
I don't think you're gonna win it anyway
yeah you're definitely gonna win it the
whole eye thing you know yeah people
okay it's not a sympathy competition
it's an actual Redemption well yeah what
did I do by the way is there wear a mask
like at least you like what is there
what is there too much light in the eyes
do we need no do you want me to cover it
yeah we put sunglasses on maybe an eye
patch okay I could cover it up if it's
freaking people out I don't want to
scare any of the audience away it looks
totally normal I don't want to make you
feel insecure well you did you look very
handsome now they're staying on for the
rest yeah I'll tell you what man you'd
be ten times more handsome to me with or
without an eye you know what I mean
thank you okay Ethan all right
uh Tana I'm getting a show note from our
producers uh we need that mic to move a
little bit closer maybe maybe I'll put
it in
the way of the nipple like okay two
birds I like that
yeah so spiciest drama was the ending of
Frenemies that was last year worst
apology was Travis Scott Astro World oh
yeah deserves it how everybody's moved
on past that and he's doing shows
already
um yeah he's like let's get it let's
recancele him let's take him down
tanacon 2 coming soon people are like
he's responsible for people like dying
what did I do make a bad joke please I
didn't call no stampede
I need like a like a fan or something or
I can just cover my face when I get
scared chat is thirsting hard for both
of you I'm getting another show note
here so congratulations thank you chat
heartthrobs we love our heart throw I
wish I could see it I wish I could read
it the whole show yes well well I'll
pass on important Notes too uh we had
I'll just go I'll just blast through
these
worst influencer song was dink dink by
Logan Paul I don't know if you guys
remember that
is that really the worst ding dong
you're my favorite coin it kind of
catches is it because of the financial
damage it did to people's lives or the
quality of the song you know what I
think it took in the totality of the
corrosiveness and the music itself the
music is a bob he's a good artist and
Creator I think he's a talent I believe
in cryptos who still I think it's well
he said it's coming back so I look it is
working I got inside info and I'd rather
not comment on it no comment what did
Jeff say no did we buy [__] no comments
let's get in now from Jeff he's out no
no no no no no well it's hot I don't
know many people on this list so I can
really only give input on my friends
which sucks you know but [__] it who
gives a [__] let's let's you're talking
about my steamies well Mike wasn't
involved in the
I don't I don't let's move I don't even
know why it came up the thing is Mike
was probably gonna get probed by the FBI
soon but he'll be fine
he'll be fine probe just let me explain
myself not like anally but like
questions okay
yeah or I don't know what the FBI has
pretty Advanced interrogation method so
maybe they will anally probe him yeah no
that's what I was wondering yeah are
they gonna go up his ass for information
on this Logan see the night shift
episode I [__] my pants today
great sound bite excellent what's up
Mike if you're watching at home I I will
take it easy all right Mike I try to
tell you time and time again you gotta
you just gotta I think you gotta Just Do
Your Own Thing at this point bro why was
he not called back for this because we
had such a good BFFs episode because
there's only there's only room for three
people at this I'm surprised I like your
guys's dynamic as you said the Frenemies
yeah because my if I brought Mike you
just take over the show yeah oh yeah I
know what you mean this show would be 50
his laugh and then like uh like a stolen
like like Steve Harvey motivational yeah
exactly or something where they were not
here to be motivational no no I
understand we're here to I never am
really
yeah we're here to be caddy glad we got
we got that figured out why Mike is not
here yeah he's he was not invited in
fact he's not allowed in the building if
he does attempt to show Fair uh the
biggest cringe moment last year was
keemstar and Aiden Ross's stream
uh worst influencer scam actually was
Austin mcbroom's YouTubers versus Tick
Tock boxing event oh yeah that's a good
one yeah worst award show
there was actually only one nominee the
Streamys
then they did they took that test yeah
they won uncontested the streamies yeah
yeah I appreciate the dead eye contact
he gives me everything you know
uh the biggest this feels illegal but
for some reason nobody faces consequence
award was of course James Charles uh
allegedly not really a legend he
admitted sexting miners his sister
snatched I heard that you are a
I heard that you are a James Charles
hater that was just like an instinct to
clap really like I couldn't fight my own
arms you know what I mean it was just
like [__] oh right um I don't I also I'm
clapping right there with you sister I
was gonna say sister the star
um most Shameless clickbait was the
lebrandt family he clicked it's called
she got diagnosed with cancer he
clickbaited his daughter being diagnosed
with did you see their like
anti-abortion documentary too yeah that
you you know that this is why you what
are they say in that she's good she's
great what did they say in the anti
there was just one line it had something
to do
with comparing it comparing abortion to
like a mass genocide a holocaust yeah I
was scared to get Clips saying no words
yeah the lebrandt family good Christian
family they go they say six million Jews
died in the Holocaust well 100 million
fetuses are killed every year
I had a viewing party for that video at
my house I needed every single person I
know to see that like I don't I don't
think I love that so much I don't think
you can be my friend like if you haven't
seen that it's gonna stop dissing the
nonsense I haven't seen it yeah I'll put
you on we'll watch it on the podcast
honestly okay it's really good okay yeah
yeah uh most uh let's see best YouTube
drama news coverage was deaf noodles who
uh had quite a year he loves me
some categories are cursed and
apparently that's one of them I I wanted
to see what I was getting into today and
I watched last years and I saw that you
had him as a co-host yeah if that's any
predictor from your guy where you guys
will go from here not good damn damn I
almost didn't show up after I saw that I
was like this is what we are now
but no I realized I realized that we had
to come in and clean up the mess that's
going on over here thank you man
I appreciate that
you're used to cleaning up messes
usually involves you know heavy
machinery but all right enough enough of
that
um and and uh let's see here oh well
this one includes you best attempt at
murdering your friend shuin was David
dobrik of course slamming you in today
so does that mean he won so I don't get
any I don't get a piece of that no he
won that award but like again attempting
to murder your friend you're the right
word you want but like if you go to my
Wikipedia page or something would that
be in my Awards section do I get any of
that no credit for that and I it's not
fair
well well we could we could I mean he's
got a point yeah we could we could work
it out with the Wikipedia people I would
like that might be able to help you in
court
that's good yeah the recognized by the
prestigious
steamies worst midlife crisis keemstar
most dramatic Creator Gabby Hannah so
that was last
and that's true right I mean she had a
heck of a year now this year's
categories are a little bit different
they're they're catered to the year
we've had a big year this year different
than last year
um the ruining of a young generation of
men award is a is a new category Andrew
the Tate the tater tots yeah love a
tater tot yeah so he's the winner of
that well I he you know some it's like
you know when Daniel Day-Lewis played
Lincoln did we think did we think he
wasn't going to win the Academy Award
you know what I mean
I mean there's other nominees but come
on do the math
uh worst influencer scam that's a
returning category me like counting my
what's tick coins at what's tits coins
at
what's it training at this year I forgot
about that I never heard of this tits
I don't remember much about it I can't
keep up with all my friends you know
there's just too many I did a couple
little crypto brand deals and then
realized it wasn't my
biggest cringe moment is a returning uh
category love worst National brain rot
discourse
little wordy but it's a new category and
we're just talking about
it's really just the most uh deranged
horrible discourse we'll get into the
nominees there okay
dumbest fat man bad ela's ugly moment
again that this is a new category
anytime someone wants to start beef with
me they call me fat and Ela ugly it's
happened so many times we actually
created a category for it so that'll be
interesting not me not when we beef
though no that's because you're a real
man dude you're a gentleman my man here
bro yeah yeah it's not too late I took
other uh routes but well respectable
right later in the show yeah by the way
please don't wear your glasses because I
made you feel insecure you're no you did
it you did the same thing to me that you
did to that girl and no actually I mean
not sorry say that we're live better
just react oh no
just a little Shredder
you okay daughter sure do I relate to
you man all right
yes
um where are we yes uh most Shameless
click bait shutters yacking really loud
worst apology
most unhinged Tick Tock account which is
a new category uh what the hell
happening dear God somebody please do
something award well yeah
worst award show is a returning category
greatest Redemption Arc you both are
nominated spiciest drama and of course
most dramatic creator
and so basically as I said the the
winner was selected we put out a
comprehensive Google kind of Excel sheet
we we sent it out to the people
and um they voted so these are all uh
voted on by the people and let's just
start let's just get wow we have all of
the results right here in these
envelopes good job wow is right here in
these envelopes wow the first category
is the ruining a generation of young men
Awards so we have a little uh Stinger
here too honor our nominees
the ruining generation of young men
award
[Music]
I like the idea of being able to just
say to do what I want fresh and fit I
think if you're in a serious
relationship with a girl she should not
have an Instagram that's cheating for
women attention is like sex for men
yeah attention from from you give a man
a microphone
relationship with a girl she's still
there and that's very disrespectful like
there's a gun off camera for sure
still talking about ugly people you are
literally the ugliest
she doesn't realize how ugly she is
that are all better than her so she
thinks that she's on the same level
Kanye and the Nazis should not be worse
hugs it shook people down to a lot of
really bad things but they did good
things too we're gonna stop dissing the
Nazis all the time man I don't like
Nazis I don't know why
[Music]
I was going to come in here with that
mascot today because all the [__] you've
been stirring up I don't want to show my
face
yeah well we got some stiff competition
there this year do you think that um the
Romanian prison will accept the steamy
award or will they consider that
Contraband wow
um no I'm sure somebody one of his tater
tots will shove it in their ass and
bring it in Contraband okay
you know I'd like to point something out
about Tate that I've noticed recently
that I find really funny just the stand
don't let him no no no no he doesn't
think I should drive
that's not true does he make you she
does not drive she she doesn't have a
driver's license she's never drove in a
car so yeah but I think it's because I'm
a woman it comes down to her no I don't
think she should drive she's legally not
allowed I'm a woman I think the you not
having a license is internalized
misogyny that's that's what
point out a thing about Tate that you
could tell that the man is a liar and a
hypocrite just off of this okay
he said that men should not have hair
because it's a sign of weakness and I
guess a hair yeah did he say that yeah
you don't meant tough men don't need
hair that's right and he chooses to
shave his own head okay Dan sorry for
you to get caught in the no no I'm just
saying and the bald King yeah so he his
argument was one good take
uh you don't need hair men don't need
hair you know just make money and all
that and he chooses to shave his head
because of those reasons but now that
he's incarcerated doesn't have the tools
to shave his head you could see that
it's other reasons yeah the hair don't
grow up here it doesn't grow actually it
looks like he had like a botched hair
transplant as well
that is true that could be one of the
things so well I didn't know he said
that so that's a very good point there
and so here let's open the envelope I'm
gonna do the first one and then we'll
rotate but basically there's a lot of
factoids on here so the winner of
ruining a generation of young men award
goes to with
68.6 percent
it's Andrew Tate
[Applause]
there was yeah and there was a lot of
competition here but he really just did
a lot this year right yeah fresh and fit
was in second place with 10 Kanye 9.8
snico with 12 Jordan Peterson was on
there with only 1.5 percent so better
luck next year Jordan
um but yeah that's that's the
congratulations and this is of course
Andrew Tate
steamy we'll be sending this to Romanian
prison and just hoping for who would who
do you think would be a good candidate
to take that uh shove that up their ass
and bring it into the jail as Contraband
well all of his associates were arrested
too yeah maybe Aiden I mean he would
need somebody that hasn't yeah probably
no priors you know somebody clean that
could get in there Aiden if you're
watching this we're gonna need to put
this in your ass so start practicing
buddy
there it is congratulations all right
so much excitement you guys
all right I give this honor to you Jeff
the worst influencer scam oh that could
be
all right go ahead roll the slider
please this is gonna be fast
scum
really fun game that makes you money
yeah that earns you money how much did
you guys make from crypto zoo I lost
around fifty thousand dollars
forty thousand dollars around fifteen
thousand US dollars I lost twenty five
thousand dollars that's such a great
point five hundred thousand dollars
and then people could buy it because I
could say that the community is super
strong and then I could sell it in 10
seconds and make 10 million dollars just
stamped his followers for up to a half a
million dollars I'm trying to like get
you to return the money because it's a
hundred percent still available and this
one's lengthy do that yeah I couldn't
get the money back it is within my power
but I'm gonna look out for myself and
not do that
we actually have a special message from
Ice Poseidon on his nominee this so this
is a rare treat go ahead this is him
responding to his nomination
[Music]
he just got himself another category
he's got nominated again fat loser well
he didn't call him Batman okay oh it's
got to be [__]
is a class action lawsuit by these guys
and several influencers who promoted say
quote the misleading they didn't know
these people did not know
they don't deserve it I agree but
they're nominated causing investors
existing Investments at inflated prices
Tai Lopez nfts
I want to talk about my nft project
called OG original garage social club by
selling a chance
how about watching a movie with Tai
Lopez for only thirty thousand dollars
but just know you're not going to be the
one to pick it Lana Rhodes uses the
Ukraine war to distract from a rebel she
fired back at me today saying you
shouldn't worry about this yeah there's
a war going on saying people who are
concerned about her scamming investors
are being stupid because quote people
are living in fear for their life in
Ukraine right now
what does this world come to I don't
feel like it needs it but um we know we
know a lot I love things can happen at
the same time
[Applause]
[Music]
we had so many good ones in there now
again
there's one that stands out to me I
think I know which one's gonna bring
this one down what is it which one is
that
it's got to be in my opinion the crypto
Zoo
he's the freshest in people's minds yeah
you know it's just fresh but in terms of
like I would come back around
you know it's not done yet right it's
worth it's too soon to call it a scam
yeah so I'm dying for it I don't know
the image should I just open this up go
ahead and rip just rip it open Jeff all
right
here we go
which is exciting worst influencer scam
winner Logan Paul and crypto zoo with
59.4 percent you know
you know what go ahead yeah go ahead you
know when I first heard of this and I
watched the coffee Zilla episode the
first one I said you know I wish I was
around back then because I would have
got in on the action early like Mike
Brown no no no no no I'm kidding Mike
Mike said that he had he he didn't get
in on any action but um it's tough for
me to comment on this because
you know
go ahead
I mean I I am I am friends with Logan a
criminal oh I mean sorry I'm friends
with a lot worse criminals than that's
true that's fair yeah one of them came
to my house I know I know I know I know
I know I know yeah so
um look
I don't know I'd like to say uh no
comment absolutely you could plead the
fifth no that incriminates yourself you
could say no comment listen you could
listen you know it's it's coming it's a
good it's a good idea it was a good idea
the little animals and the eggs you know
yeah no never been thought of before
um yeah so you know I'm gonna just go
ahead and say uh congrats Logan you know
hopefully
um
maybe next year uh best Redemption Arc
Logan Paul that's good that's the only
way to look at it keep it out hope you
gotta go low to get back and get hit the
highs again and he just did a great job
in that wrestling match did you guys see
that that he was phenomenal yeah that
was great phenomenal it's great
yeah but uh actually uh in second place
was safe Moon interestingly 15 Tai Lopez
10 ice Poseidon uh hi ice thanks for the
comments that scumbag deserved to win
this you know what the what the [__] and
Lana I'll have you know a very nice
sweet Lana Rose I didn't know what she
was getting into four percent yeah she's
barely on the charge there yeah yeah but
Logan Paul definitely I mean he he
really deserved that one this year like
I feel like he really took it down this
year
Logan Paul when he someone told him that
he had kovid and he was hanging out with
him the day before oh yeah
it was from a few years ago
oh okay yeah I mean Ethan I have friends
that say this [__] to me too so you know
I just want to be honest here I can I
can come on here and just say yes to
everything but I have a lot of scumbag
friends that I'm still involved you know
you know just because someone does
something wrong
doesn't mean that you stop being their
friend right that's what life is look at
her you know what she did she invited 4
000 people to a a event that only a
venue that only held 100 people
oh my God I forgot about that one you
know man you would have swept these in
that year yeah and now she's my best
friend yeah yeah you know yeah that's
why I was quiet during the whole
afternoon I feel that I feel that yeah
well we all have our controversies don't
we but since you're friends with Logan I
figure maybe you can um deliver drop it
off to him yeah yeah he's uh like about
240 pounds of solid muscle right now so
I'm gonna I'll give it to Mike to give
to him yeah that's that works thank you
thank you he's out of my weight class
yeah
um well
up next
quite an interesting category this one's
for you Tana we're talking about worst
influencer boxing match
[Applause]
so I will be reading this
um so
well yeah let's roll the uh
the category West influence a boxing
match moment
Matt Watson versus dads this one's so
good because of the aftermath that was a
bad one with Joe Rogan when he that's
your son and we're watching you
because I get your son probably got
cocky with you but Lucy oh I was there
for this one I lived for that I lived
for that
I lived for that head butts opponents
pretends to touch gloves oh this was
real dirty dubs super bad manner you see
that [__] yeah yeah yeah I don't like
that
Austin not illegal but it's just bad
downward five times before the match is
stopped yes oh this New York at 4am and
I I loved every second it was a great
fight actually yeah
I was playing a drinking game every time
he got hit I took a shot I don't
remember because at night you got the
perfect uh you guys are the perfect
[Applause]
I'm serious I think you took the bottle
away from me you were like stop you're
blacked out yeah yeah sounds fun we were
in New York for Fashion Week around that
time and yeah you were
I was in my hotel room watching that
while she was out at all these fashion
shows in my hotel watching a YouTuber
boxing match was it really fashion shows
you're saying it like it was something
else
it does kind of sound
the Box
the club that the performers [__] into
their hands and throw it at the audience
you went that's odd he was there you
dragged me there yes one of those nights
what would that but the Highlight was
the boxing match a little after party we
had viewing that it was good well Tana a
pretty big time A-list celeb you know we
won't say but we can drop are you trying
to name him drop it no no no no no what
happened and we can't we made a very
important celebrity join us to watch
that Austin oh he sat with you thank you
for you yeah so who so give me your hand
what are we doing what are we talking
about like which gender what gender
it's a boy um
yeah sis mail
[Laughter]
um Joker a funny man yeah just male
funny man
played played The Joker one of the ones
you guys hung out with Jared Leto either
him or Jack Nicholson he's a weirdo
right that's another one iconic like
sitting there watching Jared Leto watch
Austin McBroom get knocked out that's so
interesting was he confused by that
honestly no he was like he's a big fight
fan big fight fan are you guys still in
touch with Jared should we give him no
no I mean not not no bad blood but he
was just with another uh one of my
friends I see I see
worst influencer moment name drop yeah I
love that good opportunity he has a cold
you guys are being a woman you know it's
like uh uh no Tana stop I'm not aware of
it I have heard of some stuff but I'll
ask him next time we're watching the
next Austin McBroom fight yeah what's
the deal with that cult stuff he's a
weird guy man that Jared Leto he's got a
cold they do Retreats it's all women
sounds sick
well that's what I was saying maybe even
maybe you'd be interested in maybe I'll
get the invite you know we could go out
there if I fall off I think he he only
allows one guy him so does he I don't
think you get the invite
oh I don't know we're pretty we're
pretty tight maybe he'll allow you are
handsome maybe maybe
depending on how handsome of a man he is
you know he was the guy that Christian
Bale killed in American Psycho did you
know that he was Paul Allen I did not
know that oh my god oh yeah I see that
now I I guess I remember that crazy
right that he's been doing it for a long
time he's been around he won an Academy
Award yeah incredible still don't really
understand incredible but let's stick to
the topics here because we could talk
about Jared the winners please Tana I'm
horribly uh apologetic for talking over
here I think Jeff just had to get a
little name drop out yeah that was you
that was all you worst influencer boxing
match moment the winner is Dr Mike
pretends to touch oh that you know what
shocking you know what there was a lot
of competition this year yeah and I'm
super happy because I thought that was
just so scummy what he did yeah and I
love to see that and these are all it's
it's a pretty even like you know what I
mean Matt versus dad was 22.3 okay
Austin McBroom knocked something I can't
read that 21.7 oh wow wow fousey versus
deji was 16.5 percent Ryan Taylor was
12. and how much did the winner get the
winner it was a real tight race only 27
second place at 22 oh my goodness did
you take that
because wait
he did snag that oh an awesome room
right behind with only one percent lower
and third wow this was a super tight
race that's our closest no yeah Matt
versus dad is just so funny because the
aftermath of Joe Rogan fousey versus
deji I don't know if you guys have the
same YouTube suggested videos that I get
but I get a lot of the ones that say
um boxing before and after like gone bad
or something right so it's all the stuff
of fousey like I got in this great shape
for this and his body looked incredible
and then he got beat up by this pudgy
kid did look good you know so that one
is pretty good too I see why it's such a
tight competition here interestingly
fousey also won creator of the year at
this at the streaming did he yeah and he
gave this iconic speech this is gold I
felt ugly I felt gay I felt that no like
that
[Applause]
and then they cut to Lily's yeah Lily
sings face because I think she's bi or
lesbian yeah so he goes I felt gay and
then they cut the Lily sings do you
think he prepared that speech because it
sounds like he was almost reading it off
a teleprompter and then I don't think
that would have been on the top yeah no
but it wouldn't do though like right out
of speed because he's that horrible and
be like this is dope he's the type of
guy that always has a speech prepared
well he's not used to uh faking uh
I'm trying to work the fake pranks angle
it's not super elegant well he so he's
always got a speech prepared like even
after the fight he had a great losing
speech okay so he probably went in there
like I'm gonna have this great winning
speech if I win this great losing speech
and then I saw him after and I was like
yo that was a great speech that you gave
after you look because I didn't say
anything about the fight so it wasn't
really anything but speech about you
know how all the people that we're gonna
uh unalive themselves and that didn't
because of his body transformation I do
appreciate that yeah so that was I
didn't kill myself because Fouseytube
you got in great shape you know what you
discount that Tana but I'm sure Lucy's
ABS saved lives mine yeah that's a
testament you know what I mean I was
gonna like and I was like nah he's
ripped bro
yes we love that yeah well
um what a fantastic evening so far uh a
little surprise a couple surprises a
couple shoe-ins does that mean your
lives not living
yeah I get banned the tater tots Master
pardon you I believe every time and I
get banned for hateful wow but then it's
weird it's weird
this is a big category this is one that
I care deeply about of course it is the
biggest cringe moment
the big one guys
I think he lives in Florida so um if you
have a P.O box or something check that
yeah we're going to mail it to your
[__] house with some anthrax
I feel like I need to say something real
quick Dr Mike is really nice guy I know
I know I know yeah the reason I said
Anthrax is because he's a doctor and he
would know what it was
thank you Dr Mike obviously I don't have
access we're going to drop that off at
your [__] doctor's office hey Dr Mike
he's a nice guy you're a nice guy but a
little scummy in the ring it's a cheap
shot a cheap shot Dr Mike
we don't like what you did out there Dr
Mike
but you could redeem yourself next year
next time 23 CDs you gotta give your
opponent a kiss on the lips
all right here we go biggest cringe
moment of the nominees please
moment
dreams face reveal or dream hi everyone
thinks he's so cool for the first time
I think the whole thing was a lot why
are you trying to Addison Ray is dead
with young gravy yeah
I used to talk a lot of smack and he's
talking this gave me like an incurable
essence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Aiden Ross sniffing educates chair of
course
even as the shield yeah yeah I'm
brainwashed or I'm trying to dick suck
no
um
oh my God I don't keep up with it
garyvee posts v-con
sounds like my kind of guy
[Music]
new exclusive character just for Becon
Pfeiffer there it is guys
Dojo cat beefs
I'm just gonna say something right now
the Noah schnapp thing I'm like trying
to be super Fair that's some [__] I
would do like I never posted a private
conversation unbelievably like
filters of people buying [__]
it's my favorite thing ever when
someone's like yeah
branding and Tattoos
comedian also debuted the tribute to the
41.60
[Music]
I don't even I didn't even see the
category my biggest friend yeah no no
what are they sharing a cheese plate
fight on stream I have to go all the way
I don't like things above my head all
[__] day I [__] do this with you
anymore you are not a victim here
I have no idea
20 22 and three there it is what a stack
though now hold on what did um
what did uh Adam
I don't know you know when someone like
sends you a DM and they unsend it says
like accept or ignore like they like
shows that they sent it he backed out I
don't know
or she never opened you never opened it
like I never saw it what do you think
but he unsent it because if like okay
even if I never opened it and I went to
go look it would still be there like he
had to unsend it for that like screen is
that a real thing or is that like a
Sunday morning rain was falling that
messages disappear or the accept thing I
think it is because I've experienced
that too yeah with someone oh I want to
do that on your phone I want to see all
the people who have slid in on you and
unset okay you wanna do it live on on
the show here at some point yes okay I'd
love to do that we'll get to that after
the winner is announced so um are we
allowed to make a prediction please I'd
love to hear your prediction on that one
um I forgot the nominees I think Lopez
Monty Lopez yeah I feel like his is not
as popular because he's not that big of
a name but he deserves to win this and I
hope
that the voters pulled what were the
other ones and gave it to the right guy
here because the Aiden Ross Andrew Tate
they're so I feel like that's gonna win
yeah yeah yeah and but he was trolling
In that clip when he sniffed the chair
it was joking yeah and that was a joke
no I don't think you know I think
because he was trolling he sniffed a
little too deeply but I think he was
curious but it was a joke swinging a
miss right yeah but I don't think that
qualifies as cringe if he's putting on
an act you know so I think it has to go
because he is pure cringe and it's
genuine he's real it's down it's in his
bones you feel so bad for Addison Ray
that yeah and then her mom also
apparently slept with young gravy like
she's got a list I don't think she slept
with young gravy
I talked to her about it maybe she was
lying to me but
I don't think she was I had talked well
we talked to him about it and no I don't
know the way it was I don't know I just
want to stir the stir the pot really
really really Sly there yeah really Sly
I love Sherry I love Addison Monty on
the other hand and we love playing
traffic I think you guys are downplaying
one that's really intimate to this
community which is of course keemstar
feeding Fouseytube uh maple syrup on a
little dollop of it with a fork that's
what I see in my sleep paralysis
no question
um so this one is so let's let's take a
look I mean my goodness who could it be
this year 2022 biggest cringe moment
goes to wow
this is unexpected and very close
dreams face reveal oh wow that see
that's mean
maybe
I'm frankly shocked by this can you this
is an upset explain to me why it's
cringe let's go yeah I think it was like
Yeah The Fall the build up to it okay he
was doing like all these super cringy
collabs with all his friends like
building it up so much whoa I can't wait
for dreams face reveal like really okay
kind of really cringy and so he built up
this incredible anticipation okay and of
course it doesn't matter really what he
looked like it was gonna
that was him yeah so I think it was I
mean I hope it's not people coming at
his look no I mean if anyone starts
streaming with something on their face
like what do you expect underneath
Channing Tatum like he looks good I
don't know that's what they thought
but uh no I don't think they're making
fun of how he looks I don't know his age
but I would say I'd hit you would in
another life yes if he's over he lost a
lot of weight which I love
yeah I could see why you know he's
feeling himself he worked hard and he
wanted to show it off I don't see it as
a cringe moment I think we got robbed
here this isn't a stunning upset I have
to say what's the second one the second
one which was just a one percent
different was Addison Ray's dad that's
so yeah yeah no and then a 0.3
difference was Aiden Ross uh shaving his
head and sniffing at you's chair oh of
course that one's up there and then only
a point five percent difference was Adam
Levine sexting women followed almost
identical to Elon Musk going on stage
with Dave Chappelle that was not in the
Stinger
was it oh I forgot about that yeah I
forgot another tight race and what did
Elon Musk say he was just like I'm
[__] Rich I'm rich
yeah it was bad is this happens to um
this goes to dream so I'm listen Dream I
don't condone this the people voted
um
but this is yours and I do apologize
about that we all think you're handsome
here yeah hey Dottie daddy up yeah don't
shoot the messenger dream yeah you know
I'm just kidding he's 23 by the way so
good
oh you guys are
perfect I'm just kidding though
um Jeff I bequeathed the next award to
you my friend
worst National brain rot discourse I
don't understand this one well maybe
rolling the nominees will help
illuminate for you and everybody all
right let's roll them Ronnie West
National brain rot discourse Will Smith
slapping Chris Rock Will Smith just
smack the [__] out of it keep my wife's
name out your [__] mouth I'm going to
okay
the Johnny vs Amber trial human being
have actually
dropped a grumpy fecal matter on the bed
Junction leading your honor I'm going to
object on hearsay he's gonna that my
coach Direction your honor here say
objection hearsay her Communications are
hearsay Elon buys Twitter Twitter has
been sold to Elon Musk I decided to do
my part for democracy and leave Twitter
all together deleted the app I quit
Twitter so I was just wondering if I
could maybe look at yours is Andrew Tate
innocent so back to the the Tate [__]
have you been in contact with anyone on
that side or anything since the [__]
arrest went down nah man I have it he's
innocent until proven guilty yeah he is
a really good guy man like when I met
him he's super chills nothing like I
really like him have you ever looked at
his website where he was talking about
what his process of getting women for
the cam girl thing if he's actually
convicted for sex trafficking like it's
[__] a really bad thing I heard it was
money laundering though that's what I
heard too but then somebody who knows
somebody told me it's just the don't
worry darling drama the moments kept
coming inside the theater everybody
wondering today and I cannot believe I'm
asking this question did Harry really
spit on Chris the video going viral the
fans undecided but the headlines are
everywhere Megan thee stallion blamed
after being shot a jury has convicted
Tory Lanez of all three charges for the
2020 shooting of Magnus stallion so if
you believe the narrative that he shot
Meg you're gonna probably agree with the
fact that he had a concealed weapon in a
vehicle grossly
um he was negligent in discharging that
weapon as well so it is what it is
foreign
makes sense now yeah yeah it's hard to
choose you know I think like the Johnny
Depp one was a huge I had a huge
presence
um the Andrew Tate stuff had a huge
presence Will Smith one had a huge
president exactly so but I feel like
your fans are gonna pick Tate though
you know what I hope not I'd like to see
someone else take an award yeah well
that clip you you play a big role in
that you were able to get through to
Bradley you influenced him and he tried
to share some of that knowledge and he
got bullied bullied he got bullied so
that's pretty funny man it's pretty
funny yeah I'm sure he [__] probably
hates me now he's like [__] Ethan now
my friends hate me yeah
you're a good man Bradley yeah Bradley
you try to do the right thing man our
golden retriever King so I get it I
understand Bradley and then also I
understand
um who's the one that got shot and
blamed for it uh Megan the stallion yeah
I could relate to her too yeah you know
Jeffrey the Whitaker that was you're
right you asked me to shoot you with
this gun yeah you know so that's rough
to hear that so she might be up in there
but I don't think that's as popular I
think so yeah well let's take a look
let's just get into it here we go drum
roll please
the winner
winner of worst National brain rot
Andrew is Andrew Tate innocent
29.9 you know what guys I mean listen it
was a really just the discourse around
that was really a nightmare you know
what I mean uh second place was Elon
buying Twitter understandable that was a
big [__] show yeah and then third Johnny
and Amber you know it's dated so that's
probably why they came in in third but
human fecal matter well Aiden Ross I
hope you've got a nice spacious butthole
because that's too much
and I'm not quite sure if he maybe I
think this comes apart Aiden if you want
to do it compartmentalize it you can
take it out no wait a minute isn't that
a word actually for Aiden because it's
the people
defending saying that he's innocent you
know what I think you might be right
yeah we'll see there you go so if I ever
do visit Aiden Ross he did send me his
address I'll I'll drop this off didn't
you just message his address yes he did
Tim can I have that for like
research you know absolutely how did
that come about he was like um we've
been having it back and forth and he was
on a stream he's like you know I'm gonna
send Ethan my address I want him to come
over and so we can like talk it out and
I didn't see I didn't know the context
so I just got a DM from him and I was
like what do you want to do with this
and then I saw the the VOD the next day
and I was like okay I'm gonna go to
Aiden Ross's house I was gonna just
gonna show you just sick of responding
to videos because I just kept seeing the
little small box of you guys reacting to
each other and then it was it was
running out of room so you're like now
you got to meet in person yeah good
that's exactly what happened and I was
gonna dress up like Morpheus because I
wanted to offer a chance to exit The
Matrix and uh he dodged me he didn't
even stream that day and I was prepared
to go so Aidan Ross you're a coward I've
been seeing him in the gym he's been
lifting weights maybe that's what he did
that day he went to go pump some iron
and get his his anger out fine I've been
there I've been hitting a punching bag
thinking about you oh yeah yeah yeah
so
maybe that's what he was doing that day
he is against masturbating he is a semen
retention your thoughts on that
I don't believe it I think he's just
saying that you don't think it so you
don't think he actually what's the point
of SEMA retention to build testosterone
yeah it's not real but that's what they
think
are you saying that no I think it's a
real thing it's in boxing they tell you
not to release for weeks before your
fight I think it just makes them laugh
it was a hard time I don't think it
doesn't increase your testosterone what
was that
sorry well I think yeah what was that so
that was a hard time for me did she date
any boxers
no is there any boxers which boxer was
that it was just a joke just okay sorry
that's when we moved past it um all
right well congratulations
um this one you have the the honor of
doing Tana
yeah the dumbest Batman bad Gila is ugly
moment this is gonna be a fun one I do
not agree with thank you so much to the
Hilo one she's so fine yeah
um do you think all fat people are wrong
just by default
I thought you thought that well that no
I've learned that from becoming fat I've
learned that
basically you are not allowed to hold
people invalidate anything you believe
in or do just because you're fat it's
quite an interesting phenomenon like fat
phobia in today's society yeah fat hate
I don't think the two relate but I think
it's an easy jab you know yeah yeah for
sure oh look at this guy he's fat I
could just say that and then it's gonna
take too long for him to change that
about it and too much work you know okay
so then maybe that'll sit in his head
and that'll end this argument but you
don't let that ever get to you no no you
know you just use that as fuel for your
fire oh yeah which is good and I think
you're setting a good example for people
out there but not for all much anymore
because you're dropping all these pounds
you're leaving well I'm on my way and
thank you for noticing but you can be
like Jared from Subway without the whole
pedophilia yeah I didn't like you could
just be like yo look at my pants and I'm
chill here's the thing how do we know
that it wasn't the sex with kids that
made him lose the way
uh uh really really strong point over
there Ethan but uh doing both I don't
know if there's a direct correlation no
I think it was the Five Dollar Foot
Longs man there we go here we go
Hannah brought up Jared to trigger
warning Tana
he's in jail now by the way live I'm not
if he gained the weight back in prison I
mean just to be clear like I'm not a
Jared from Subway fan I'm more of the
yokiro Taco Bell dog girl fan you know
that whole thing was [__] though who
believed that he lost all that weight
for me he said look at my school when I
was a kid in Middle School oh yeah a lot
of people that was like a huge freaking
campaign for them that was like that was
like subway was the moment yeah do you
remember this I remember your school he
came to my school oh God dodged a bullet
there right yeah well I don't think he
was interested in stop saying things
Santa oh my God yeah um and I yeah I
don't I don't know when you team me up
about like pedophilian stuff because I
take the bait I think if you didn't know
with that it would be a way broader
concern Here Comes you ever see the
South Park episode where they made fun
of Jared they said he had AIDS oh yeah
very good it was uh yeah
that also is uh well they were onto
something a people with AIDS all right
all right
here we go
dumbest fact man bad Ela is ugly moment
Steve will do it h3h3 no he doesn't work
out so I can't take his can't take it
serious can't take his opinion seriously
damn I want to be a 250 pound podcast
host with with an ugly wife and just
talk [__] about oh
I'm gonna dog his wife
and you know that is Ethan decline he's
fat as [__] he never wants to change
and I know you want an in-shaped husband
but it is what it is Andrew Tate all
right so someone sent me this link I
looked it up there's this heifer this
out-shaped dude and then there's some
other really out-shaped chick and then I
realize obviously they're just jealous
because they're both obese well I don't
watch his [__] Channel I don't watch
fat dudes why the [__] what I listen to
him I would rather sleep in a bed by
myself every night for the rest of my
life then marry a woman who looked like
that fresh and fit get the [__] out of
here if you don't like getting bullied
go on [__] H3 I don't know someone
needs to bully it [__] hit the class
so he can lose some goddamn weight and
get away from that ugly [__] that he's
married to because this [__] is starting
to get ridiculous
you take some good stuff on that what do
you think I want to make sure that
you're hurt yeah impression fit this is
me letting you know right now that it is
my main goal to go on your podcast it's
the only thing I'm leaving with today I
think I'll delete my Instagram
whatever you need you guys would
absolutely slay I would love to see you
guys on fresh and fair right yeah I
think you would do really well there
honestly let this practice he goes all
right so I think that women should
basically not work and stay indoors
until their husband comes home and then
you have to walk behind them when in
public
thoughts
I mean
I feel like I would just go low blow I'd
be like okay what's your net worth you
know what I mean let's fight let's go
outside right now
you and me that's a good all our friends
can watch that's awesome you guys really
just cut right through the [__] you
know yeah yeah Jeff's gonna physically
assault them and I'm gonna go for them
money Shannon so uh that's good yeah
what is your net worth these days I
don't know should we call Kathy my
accountant shout out Kathy it's probably
pretty good right it is it's it's doing
good I'm about to buy a house
congratulations I'm very happy thanks
guys it's all beat picks really it's not
an esteemed it's very no but it's very
nice I'm glad you're doing well I think
Jeffrey doing well too with the
barbershop items and stuff oh yeah yeah
it's doing real well nice plug you gave
me over here thank you for that man an
AB too hey I got some nice presents for
you guys but because we were running
late today I don't want to throw it
together last minute so I'm gonna send
you guys a nice package this week
genuinely love your product thank you
the smell phenomenal thank you right
down it's so phenomenal I love it I use
the vomit every day and um it's edible
too
kind of crackers use the Pomade with
yeah you know the Pomade is not the
deodorant is all natural ingredients so
technically you can eat it I'm like
telling people to eat them they're not
eating do not eat it there's plenty
other things to eat and it's a why would
you buy this deodorant to eat you know
no I don't know Pana says we can eat it
so I'm taking her word for it I'm trying
to get nominated for my next steamy
right here you know eat the Pomade
definitely put it in your hair look at a
B and you know that's all I need to say
cut the baby's hair oh my my camera's
not working yeah oh look at that
effortless look how it holds thank you
thank you it would have been nicer if
you had a bow tie but what is it would
have been nicer if you had a bow tie it
looks better on you it's all good Jeff I
use the Pomade as well oh hell I'm
waiting for that let me see that I love
that [__] oh my god oh wait we got one
oh my goodness look at these guys and
where can you love to see it well what
about our bald friend over here I don't
I don't use the problem
the deodorant on deodorant smells good
deodorize your Dome bro I don't sweat
out of my Dome
oh that's true yeah where can people buy
your wonderful uh beautiful
barbershop.com thank you thank you for
that and you're available on only fans
yeah
thank you Kyle that's nice and then only
fans YouTube all that type of stuff oh
we'd like to your wine by the way did
you yeah we enjoyed it I actually
couldn't watch it I'm not even thinking
I gave it a good rating really yeah we
did wait I love that that makes me so
happy The Dizzy wine it was we all
really liked it actually dude I sipped
like half that can and I was feeling
like a little bit well four of those
little cans equate to a bottle of wine
so it's kind of lethal yeah um but you
know it is what it is I'm I never got to
try the wine because I'm sober but if I
were to relapse I would do it with Izzy
that's such a compliment bro
yeah I'm about to move into the Cannabis
space though
[Laughter]
all right all right dumbest Batman bad
Sheila is ugly award the winner
is Steve will do it really
Steve will do it
there's something unexpected I think
it's a popularity contest this is this
voting uh process is becoming a
popularity well agent Ross came in last
well the thing is that Steve kind of
went all out in a way that other people
didn't he goes he's fat and I'm just
gonna say it his wife is ugly Jesus
Christ yeah he did go all out to be fair
irony with this though Steve will do it
is the only person on that list who
apologized yeah he did he's the only one
of all those people who was he was more
legitimate about it I'm a Stan that
should probably void his
also he jerked off his dog I don't know
if you guys heard about that but that's
not this category no jerking off Dog no
but I was just saying as an aside little
fun fact about uh about Steve is that he
has jerked off his dog for example when
I jerk off Donnie uh allegedly of course
cheers like you should organize it he
didn't I saw it or he said it he said it
yeah so can we just talk about how Shane
Dawson was wildly canceled for the cat
thing but he just said it Steve will do
it said it and he's on Rumble thriving I
think Shane maybe wasn't maybe it wasn't
just this [__] on the cat but maybe
other things in combination with that do
you think that Shane Dawson or Jeffree
Star deserve a Redemption Arc
you know what I'm not super familiar
with all the exploits of
um Jeffree Star but I can say of Shane I
mean I mean
I don't know what deserves me I mean
he's pretty gross dude like certain
people I feel like do something that's
does he deserve to come back no he
doesn't no he should get in a hole like
Saddam Hussein and [__] stay there
[Laughter]
let's just you know lower them food and
they can fit in the same bucket that's
what I think yeah I like that so what
about me made you
not to make it all about myself decide
that I deserve a Redemption Arc
um Shane Dawson
comparison you look really good compared
to Shan I mean what have you done except
you know
uh I think people died of heat stroke
fatalities were hundreds twenty thousand
hundreds of deaths um hundreds yeah
um so I mean just no there are zero
deaths there were no debts at tanacon no
deaths so I think I think everyone's
kind of moved on from that like a bare
minimum around here
I think that should be talked about more
you know but there were no deaths I
think that's a huge plus yeah Travis
Scott cannot say that nope yeah No
tanacon 2 coming soon but I think
everyone kind of you know worked their
way through that and then what was the
other one tits coin I mean I feel like
that wasn't like a scandal I did a brand
new yes so you're talking about um
you're talking about tanacon I don't
honestly I don't even remember the thing
of the thing about Shane is like you're
talking about like sexual deviancy which
is very hard to get over so you're just
doing criminal fraud
what you hasn't participated in let's be
real I mean I I haven't done any you've
never really been a scammer none I've
done other crimes well you kind of are
low-key but but never since I've become
an influencer I think I got it all out
of my system that's what matters before
that's where had I had a jail era
maybe I would have had a little more wit
yeah no more you know would have known a
little more yeah but just put be cool
now obviously don't do any more scams
and fraud and stuff okay yeah I work on
it and we can keep it we can keep it
going yeah seriously but no I'm very
happy that you're that you're uh here
I'm not prison
um anyway so yeah that one goes to Steve
will do it 34 fresh and fit 28 Andrew
Tate 19
Ross uh 5.9 so there it is two Steve
will do it and I like when people win
that we actually have a chance of giving
them to so you probably cross paths with
them oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah you
can take that one Steve remind me if I
forget uh I got this baby for you yeah
but we've buried the hatchet Steve is a
good man I'll probably bump into him uh
octagon side of the UFC event or
something like that you know yeah of
course good man thank you very much all
right Jeff uh this one's for you bud
most Shameless click bait oh am I in
this one we'll see no what have you done
to earn a spot there man I don't know
it's all the bathroom boys I put the
blankets don't read it yet we need the
Stinger oh yeah sorry yeah
oh most Shameless click bait
the quartering dude I'm [__] myself
shooting my basement it's all dumb I'm
not taking a pause to pee it's all dumb
uh-oh Philip DeFranco
[Music]
Ethan Klein
it is I am going to spend the next three
days homeless in Los Angeles with the
last day being the most dangerous Street
Skid Row a lot of homeless people how
they make money they collect a lot of
trash cans and they give them to a place
that they give them money to buy alcohol
and win
be homeless it's really crazy did he
actually go through with it yeah he did
but it was like really weird just to
like cosplay I was like they weren't
here
but anyway what the Burger King can play
this week I was living for it oh you're
talking about Trisha yeah what did she
do you were saying this guy cosplayed as
a homeless person I said that's
something she cosplayed as a Burger King
I honestly live for when she does it
yeah praying for the reconciliation of
you and Trisha well brother that ain't
happening not in this lifetime you don't
think so like ever there's stuff bygones
be bygone let's do it for the people
there's there is stuff
that
there's stuff that even not even between
me and Trisha that goes too deep
did she hit you with a crane and then
blame you for it to their entire well
are you making up yeah are you making up
with David that's what I'm saying you
know you make something David I'll make
up with Trish show some I started
something I shouldn't have that's what I
mean that's what I mean some beef scampi
some people just will never I'll make up
able to see eye doctor I'll have a great
[__] week wait what did what was the
falling out with you and James
um or just him being a weirdo we were
friends for a really long time and like
it's actually I had a friend over
yesterday who was like referencing the
era who would always hang out with us
and they were like it was so horrible to
watch because you guys couldn't go one
hour without fighting like scream
fighting like we would just uh yes
absolutely nothing angry at each other
absolutely what would he yell at you
about
everything
um and honestly I will say at that time
you know I was not as
equipped in this influencer world and I
probably was late to things and I
probably deserved a late at things
related to things or you know what I
mean I didn't edit a video on him but it
just would escalate so you edited videos
for him no for me like if we did a
collab you're getting mad at you she
would just escalate crazy we would fight
absolutely crazy and eventually it kind
of just was a mutual decision that like
this and I just I'm sure he maybe didn't
agree with things I did but I also
didn't agree with things he did that I
would see and it was just kind of it
wasn't sure was one of the things you
disagreed with uh sexting miners I never
saw him sext a minor I but okay cool
but I
some of the practices that just ever I
don't we're just
very different people and yes yeah you
know slay sister
snap yeah well uh that is very
interesting so um let's just pass now I
just
it's fun to make jokes occasionally yeah
I'm not I'm no longer like
that's nice and he's friends with all my
friends so all right let's love you guys
let's get to the winner here you find it
incredible that like of all the
influencers who have been quote unquote
canceled I would find it hard to
associate with him
because he's like a Serial predator
all right should we get to it
this [__] is live so I'm like all right
here we go most now you're
out
I was saying this the other day it's
like if you if you open your career on
here
if you open your career with just not
giving a [__] like you like the way you
talk like I almost wish I did that you
know the way that Jeff can get away with
making so much more Rogue jokes than I
because he's he's a rogue people say
once you apologize for one thing you've
you know I mean not I apologize all the
time just apologize what are you doing
now let's do an apology segment right
now I'm just gonna go around and I have
I got a lot to apologize for you take it
then we're we've been steering clear of
everything so we don't have anything to
apologize for at the moment oh it's just
me then I already did the apology thing
yesterday okay so should we get to the
winner here that did something yesterday
okay let's get to the winner here so
most people find out can we just get
this drum roll sorry I just want to get
this over with you're you're getting
angry right here I know it's a side
effect of brain damage all right the
winner is shouldn't be funny but it is
[Laughter]
[Music]
Spanish drinking and looking through the
glass
Ethan Klein
wow okay 49
wow I graciously accept this actually I
I do you like to make a speech I thought
I was gay
[Music]
wow this is so unexpected and what an
honor it is here to win a steamy it's
just this might be my first steamy oh
can I get the acceptance music Zach
okay okay good I got it yeah so I felt
worthless I felt ugly
I felt gay I felt no but that's just
based on what they told me they told me
no but uh listen click baiting is a way
of a life you understand after a certain
time on YouTube that you just gotta do
it you just can't be the good guy
forever and sometimes you got to pretend
that like you know you're have cancer
or in the sometimes you just got to
pretend that your child has cancer like
the Brand family I wouldn't do that and
I've always said that yeah
[Music]
but wow what an honor you know thank you
to everybody who clicked them knowing
that they probably were clickbait
and uh those those videos actually do
tend to get more views believe it or not
so I thank you all for making this
possible thank you for the vote
and uh I do think lebranch should have
won this uh you know with that cancer
saying your child has cancer for
clickbait is just demonic you superseded
that I don't know but crazy but I
dedicate this one to the the Brand
family because you are the go so thank
you guys and we can't forget about
Philip DeFranco you're in second place
all right you scumbag we know what
you're doing
do you have beef with Phil no I just see
his thumbnails and I'm actually like you
guys both have good thumbnails oh thanks
bro
yeah Philip DeFranco with 26 I really
blew this court this category out around
49 quartering 23
phidius nobody knows who the [__] that
is he got point five percent so
congratulations to me yeah well it is
your audience and they have to deal with
the click bait so I'm not surprised why
they all voted for you because they're
probably pissed off it's you can get you
you make them worried about you you're
in the hospital I needed surgery I'm
gonna die and then of course they click
it and then it should be relieved I'm
okay
well that's a the cat that's not what
the category is it's that they're being
it's beautiful you know he click baits
that but you're just online needing
surgery about to die and you're the
honest one and you don't even click bait
it well did you I mean
how am I not going to click bait it not
show my face no but it's not it's not
click bait if it's real Photoshop and
eye open that's perfect how the [__]
would I not click bait the eye you know
no I I think that you've got a really
good thing going there with the eye I
know yeah thank you for a lifetime
clickbait you should thank David maybe
just for a lifetime I do every day I
wake up in the morning thank him
Instagram life I look in the mirror and
say thank you David I saw the comments
on my surgery post so much sympathy bad
[__] so sad no I didn't I just got
the surgery I'm just getting them now
for clout that's what I was thinking may
I yeah I would that was sarcasm in case
it's pulled up in a [__] courtroom
honestly send me the doctor when [__]
gets real bad Jeff are you single at the
moment are you do you have a significant
other due date and I'm single yeah are
you into dating or are you kind of a
single guy well at this moment in my
life I got a lot going on that I need to
sort out and I wouldn't want to bring
another
another person into my life right you
want to be there yeah yeah and I want to
have my my stuff together you know I
don't want this version of me to be what
they get you know I personally think
that's you know what I mean I was about
to [__] on everything you just said I
think it's a defense mechanism though to
an extent that you just don't want to
let somebody in because the right person
would love you and support you Hannah's
talking about himself of course no I'm
not catch me the [__] out of that we're
not doing this okay I told you already
it's not happening okay sorry sorry but
I actually are you like me I think that
was nice to you that was an Italian
makes a very insightful uh point there I
like our friendship that guy wouldn't
want it to be yeah yeah it's we're doing
therapy working to work oh [__] yeah
yeah yeah but sometimes I just go out
and I'll run like 10 miles and then I'll
call my therapist and be like I'm good
I'm good for today I don't need you
figured it out that's awesome well but
I'm doing it I'm doing all the stuff you
know well you've got all the baddies in
your DM so they're all waiting for you
can't see them
Shame Shame
um this one goes out to Tana big
category for you worst apology so
everything comes full circle you know
this is a big one and it's hilah is this
uh
a special category a fellow
train wreck apologist I am stoked to
read these
oh okay so let's go ahead and roll it
please yeah and I'm sorry
the liver King yeah yes I've done
steroids and yes I'm on steroids
monitored and managed by trained hormone
clinician liver King the public figure
was an experiment to spread the message
to bring awareness to the 4 000 people a
day who kill themselves the 80 000
people a day that try to kill themselves
our people are hurting at record rates
so I made it my job to model teach and
preach a simple elegant solution called
ancestral living the nine ancestral
tenants this is my fight this is why I
exist the try guys cheating scandal I
don't know that we'll ever be able to
fully articulate the pain we feel at
this moment it's hard to re-watch old
videos that we love and are proud of
we're losing a friend we're losing
someone we we built a company with we
have countless memories with we just
made a TV show together it's I'm sure
many of you feel the same way it's weird
we're sorry that this ever happened and
we don't know what more to say Ned also
posted his own statement which said
family should have always been my
priority but I lost focus and had a
consensual workplace relationship I'm
sorry for any pain that my actions may
have caused to the guys and to the fans
but most of all to Ariel the only thing
that matters right now is my marriage
and my children and that's where I'm
going to focus my attention
comeback stream wait do I have more
viewers than everyone else on Twitch
wait I [__] do should I just go
offline
any publicity is good publicity as an
employee what do you need to know about
it first sexual harassment is against
the law and it's against your company's
policy sorry
you looked really tense no I really
don't like it when you do that can you
please stop
what is he doing is he watching a sexual
harassment as a legal video oh come on
dude word around the offices you've got
a fat [__]
yes I do you make it look worse by
making a joke out of it how am I making
it a joke you think it's a joke Logan
Paul's first response to Coffee Zilla
you've made very real errors with very
real repercussions I'm going to be
defending myself with facts as you
continue to morph from an investigator
to a gossip Channel he's nothing more
than the keemstar of crypto and finance
I suggest you use the money you got for
pumping your patreon to hire a good
lawyer you're gonna need it coffeezilla
is not a criminal Z Here Andrew Callahan
so I'd like to start by thanking every
single person just came out in the past
week to speak about different ways in
which my behavior has made me feel
uncomfortable pressure that being said a
lot of the things that have been said
online about me are not true a lot of
things are missing really important
contextual information that I think
would change people's interpretation of
a lot of these situations but I'm not
here to invalidate anybody's lived
experience
oh lots of uh sorrys there unfortunately
the one I issued yesterday was unable to
make the category you qualify for next
year next year's yeah this the next time
you'll probably do some worse stuff by
the end of the year oh yeah they were
just I mean this is only the first month
program patiently awaiting our first
joint apology that'll be fun like that's
going to be the best day ever that's as
long as it's not for anything that bad
which it won't be because we're good
people yeah I guess we just don't do
anything that bad yeah nice yeah I
didn't really now let's get to the
scumbags I didn't deserve the categories
we
I was there's a little bit of drama
through it
maybe you can just say what it was
without getting into it because you
don't get into it I just got I'm being
sent
um a fellow Vlog Squad member calling me
a liar and Todd you're a piece of [__]
if you're watching this scum let's do it
on our yeah you can do it on your time
yeah Jeff definitely doesn't want to get
into this live but the explosive and the
emotionally driven impulsive impulsive
really
um I would just love to dive in but I'm
not
um yeah I wouldn't want to ruin media
trading as Ethan where you know it's
yeah it's such a your rectacular magical
night here and let's save it all for
positivity and taking down the the
people that are on the category that's
so wisely spoken by dear sweets
can I ask one question
if you just want to wrap it up you go
ahead what was he calling you a liar
about if you could just you you could
Pie by [__] I feel like you want to wrap
it up I don't I would love to dive in
and buy the appetizer yeah and I'd
rather just it's on public novel read it
read it yeah I didn't [__] lie so I
was like a day I'm just curious but I
understand anyways worst apology winner
Logan Paul's First Response oh
damn and you guys see that that way you
know I so [__] I also love Logan do you
hate that you have two Logan apologists
sitting here
uh listen I saw that you I saw that
before it went live because you know it
was like I was at Mike's house and they
were like what so what do you guys think
of this and I was like it's great
[Laughter]
that's awesome I was like damn this is
gonna [__] get you out of all this
[__] bro
so in a way you are kind of yourself
never go to Jeff for my future yeah yeah
I've never apologizing for some [__] I'm
calling you I've been I I think I could
give good advice at this point in my
life but I love the context of it well I
just looked at it like you know he
didn't like I obviously I didn't even
talk to him about I'm not hitting him up
and being like yo what's what's your
thoughts on this I need to know you know
I just asked Mike and Mike's like yo you
never sold anything he didn't [__]
leave her any money so I'm like oh there
was Logan didn't profit off of it he
didn't like steal any money so that's
why I was just like yeah bro you go post
that [__] you're gonna [__] crush it
and then it was I think in my opinion
for my money the worst response slash
topology video in the history of YouTube
damn it was a really really my job was
on the ground [__] I watched it like
several times private definitely because
I just was enjoying it so much yeah
don't ask me that was awesome bro so
you're kind of like a secret agent yeah
yeah looking like a double agent I just
wear tuxedos all the time so you don't
even know that this was required for
today's shoot
um second to that we have liver King at
24.5
try guys cheating which
okay
Miss Kiff comeback stream and then
Andrew
Callahan yep yeah I will say since you
guys don't seem super Savvy on the Logan
Paul thing uh he didn't make money but
he did insider trading I bought a bunch
of stock in it they colluded to buy a
bunch of stock before it went public
which is illegal but uh I'll let you
guys be oh yeah bro I just like to watch
him wrestle yeah me too
yeah me too he's really good at
wrestling
wrestleman good
Batman dad asked what's happening in my
hands wrestle man nice
Russell the bear well this one
congratulations Logan Paul I'll serve
this to you with the subpoena that's
soon to come are you suing it no well
he's going to be subpoenaed by probably
the feds soon oh yeah I think so do you
think he's going to jail
I but I I doubt who's gonna go to jail
but I do think there's going to be some
interested authorities
fine no I don't have any Insider info
neither do I yeah
wrestle man good
nothing's happening up here I mean he is
Walnut shaking around it don't even make
any sense how that big muscular man
could fly through the air like that he's
like an acrobat so athletic yeah yeah
let's leave it at that I mean look I
don't give I don't even give a [__] no
it's all good I like it we can leave it
at that
um okay so up next is my presentation of
the most
unhinged Tick Tock account
wow go ahead let's roll it I'm excited
most unhinged Tick-Tock account PNP I
got my great client here he was charged
with the second time DUI uh he
admittedly overdosed on multiple
different drugs that night it caused a
drug-induced psychosis he crashed with
two other cars on a freeway and flipped
over a few times the fire department
came with the police used the jaws of
life dragged him out of the car he
started fighting with them they charged
him with resisting arrest also
um and we're pleased to announce that
he's getting out of this with just a wet
Reckless really turned his life around
how you feeling okay thank you so much
ladies for everything I've done let's go
paint it butter Craig the smell of
Virgin peanut butter
[Music]
the Virgin peanut butter tastes the best
I just relapsed in for bread well fond
all my flummy fetus
[Laughter]
my heart flutters when I'm around you
you recognize me check this out one give
it a whiff
the strawberries
you pick strawberries anal strawberries
yeah you like them gross
the flashlight guy very rare very hard
to find especially in this condition the
tire the Treads are all there you
usually never see the Treads they're
usually worn down you can't even fit
like a nickel head in there tell you
this all the time
and usually listen
but it's time for real do not
sleep on this one folks
Howie Mandel when my friend Neil bent
over this happened does somebody know is
this covid related and if it is what do
we do about it
ow
restaurant is mine yeah yeah well that
that was actually a really thrilling
category lots of really uh powerful
nominees there for sure breathtaking
yeah Ken I saw you had a visceral
reaction to the flashlight and the
peanut butter guy the peanut butter was
since really a visceral reaction I just
serious I don't know what it
what a peanut butter is for toast
bananas okay you do eat it yeah it's
chill man but like when people start
putting it all over themselves the
peanut butter baby is a video that I
would wipe from the internet over maybe
everything ever like it it actually
gives me like severe I was gonna say age
yeah is that Nick yeah but it's more
than a Nick it you know and ick is like
livable yeah that it does something to
me like like I was clenching everything
every whole phobia perhaps borderline
yeah you'll be delighted to know that
that man featured there he puts his dick
inside the peanut butter
why I mean also a uh that goes without
saying yeah it's kind of inferred for
sure also we were going to have him on
this or we had him on the show once it
was hilarious and then I wanted to have
him back on and apparently he's
allegedly also a child predator so he
should link with uh oh yeah he should
link with the flashlight guy and do a
collab so they could maybe do a peanut
butter the flashlight guy is cool he's a
comedian but yeah yeah he's super fun
very fun don't sleep on this one he said
in there that was nice a nice selling
point yeah he's good
uh I was there was the first one in that
the the drunk driving
yeah yeah yeah the lawyer that's an
account I would watch because that's
great yeah PNP he's on Tick Tock this
guy did drugs and beat up his mother and
I'm getting him off with community
service I think I saw one recently that
was like murder yeah he was suspected of
killing her husband and I got her off on
like imagine that like interaction just
watching that first hand like all right
so Deborah here you know he told me is
that enough like like he said enough oh
yeah no they're terrible like the person
that the lawyers let's go
that's enough we get it the machine you
would do well you know what he told me
he says that he just blitzed them he
just takes the phone out and starts
going oh yeah yeah yes he does I love
that you have to like find that out I of
course one of my first questions for him
he's a great guy though really good guy
so funny and what's a person gonna do
like they were about to go to jail for
life yeah what are they going to say
they're about to start renegading you
know it's funny he's actually working
with my
uh the babysitter slash Nanny that we
work with has having some legal issues
and I [__] asked David PMP and he's
working he's working with you yeah
honestly somebody making jokes oh [__] I
should get him oh my God my good side
nice
well we're gonna get him on the show but
then we saw you guys had him on the show
like the week we were trying to get him
on we were like this is going to be too
many oh you copy H3 comments too much
please have PP on your show he's a great
guy yeah I want to meet him you guys
think I copy H3 now I brought my crew
here to do Intel they're doing research
in the background taking pictures of
everything he's got Zach's whole sound
bite Library so keep them coming keep
those comments coming because we're
absolutely we got some big plans for you
please call haters we love it now the
family family I'm just I'm joking around
yeah well the winner is let's get mad
37.3 I don't want that smoke winner is
PNP our boy David that's incredible
for sure like the peanut you know what
that's a real life [__] that guy's
problems yeah like like peanut butter
flashlight like they're just mentally
ill maybe I I would say that's probably
a good a good Venture maybe not the
flashlight guy maybe peanut butter was
in second 25 info bread uh 15 uh the
Fleshlight guy Malik
lazriel 15 and Howie Mandel uh as much
as we talked about him and enjoyed him
last year only six percent so I feel you
expect it from Howie Mandel like the
[__] that comes out of his mouth no no
pun with the whole [__] thing but I
didn't expect to see a prolapse on my
feed to be frankly oh did he actually
like that green screen like can you guys
play the unedited one for for Tana thank
you guys seriously oh boy I woke up
today and I was like
um it's like a H3 joke that I'm not in
on you know okay usually I know what you
guys are talking about but I don't know
what the [__] thing is I'll show you
the lore this is the Genesis of of what
one has the best sound bite and the best
meme can I ask a [__] up question
though sure oh I guess Tick Tock is for
tick tock is for young people so that's
inappropriate so that's why that's wrong
we're gonna say well yeah you can't post
pornography nudity okay but now that it
wasn't just pornography nudity it was
like a fully prolapsed [__] I took it
down okay did someone have is someone
able to pull that up for our viewing
pleasure
it's pretty disturbing and well it was
on obviously have to no you know you do
this was on Tick Tock kids saw this it
was up for today I get it I get it I get
it I get it I kind of I've never seen
one closer what close your eye
does somebody know is this funny related
and if it is what do we do about it
ow when my friend Neil bent over this
right that's an actual [__] yeah
that's real and then we went down a
whole Rabbit Hole of uh no fun again
yeah prolapse hold yeah we talked to
like the bit the most famous prolapser
his name is hunger FF there's famous
prolapse it's a type of porn incredibly
talented and I'll tell you what we had
Howie Mandel on the show and we had
hunger FF live prolapse for him
no yes it did happen it's like a thing
you can just feel like you could just
like it's like a party trick yes well
yes in a way yeah well for for this uh
gentleman hunger FF that we had on he he
it's like a fetish thing and he he's
okay he's a performer he's a sex
performer how do you how does one obtain
lots of crashes lots of practice things
things inside things making it come out
with the things going inside can I are
you up for seeing another video
absolutely okay good Jeff if you're
uncomfortable we have so many categories
to get to you know oh no we're waking up
with don't worry you have somewhere to
be Jeff
no I [__] I wish I thought of something
quicker and now I couldn't think of
anything just stuff what I'm going to
show you now move on it's really just
like I'm no I like this is my favorite
thing to do yeah it's education
is in this clip we put it together as
kind of the ultimate prolapse
compilation for educational purposes of
course and it's only like a minute long
so don't worry it's not going to take
too long uh but go ahead and roll it
whenever you guys have the opportunity
and thank you guys you know education is
just my number one goal we're looking
for it we might need to Circle back to
this okay that's fair that's kind of fun
like a fun little yeah mid-show and Jeff
if you couldn't handle young gravy
perform well it'll come full circle oh
no I still haven't watched it yeah yeah
I'm not serious I still I've closed my
eyes I've never seen anything like it in
my whole life it's well I just dropped
it in chat let's open it we're going for
it yeah yeah I mean you you know you you
control your body you you decide what
you want to look at right he's blind
yeah
you look like
totally 100 thank you yeah
[Music]
yeah so all right so here we go I'm
looking away
oh come on no no no no no no
[__] man I forgot what we were doing
you know what no I'm done I'm done
enough okay all right there's my
favorite part coming up if you're
interested they go ask to ask is this
where you come every time that's yeah
that's where I got
okay well you've seen enough and I've
never seen anything like it me either
yeah I didn't know that was a thing it
kind of resembles like beef carpaccio
similar texture and color yeah
I'm hungry
we have some salami I'm getting them in
the fridge well congratulations PMP
let's go ahead and move it on to
you we'll get to see that video now no
no no Evan's name then you'd be on your
house you gotta be permanently banned
yeah big time there you go Jeffy okay
what the hell is happening award what
the hell is happening award
wow the Beast one is a very exciting
category me daily crazy times we're
living in and that's what this category
is about
thank you current state of the world
let's let's roll it uh the what the hell
is happening dear God somebody please do
something award
Adriana chechik breaks back at twitchcon
she broke her back chechik later
tweeting well I broke my back in two
places and I'm getting surgery to put a
metal rod in for support today send your
support when it rains it pours and I am
definitely feeling the rain right now
man goes into Gabby Hannah's house and
films tick tocks
foreign
[Music]
everybody I'm literally inside of the
house right now just chilling with Gabby
Hannah
no you know who I am come on why did you
lie to me this whole time
why did you lie to me that's for my acne
you dumb get the [__] out of my house
now now now
amaranth live stream exposes her abusive
husband I would lock my doors but he
broke that too I ran in here to call the
cops and he literally kicked the door in
and done with this [__] you want me to
tell them I'm single it's about to be
true piece of [__] go [__] yourself
small dick anyways and I don't have to
wear cleavage every day
I can wear clothes
[Music]
Ezra Miller kidnaps someone the parents
claim that Ezra Miller was grooming
their daughter Kata ironized since uh
Takata was 12 years old if they are they
are living together Charles traveling
together now across the country they say
that they went and and confronted both
Takata and Ezra to try and get her to
return home they did get her home for a
little bit and then she returned to New
York City to meet up with Ezra and
they've continued to just travel around
Logan Paul's Pig found near death in a
field the gentle Barn Animal Sanctuary
shared a rescue story about a pet pig
they claimed this pig was once owned by
a huge influencer and was later found by
them ditched in some field with extreme
health issues she's lucky to still be
alive we were told she belonged to a
famous YouTuber and was irresponsibly
re-homed that pig was in fact Logan
Paul's mini teacup pig that he purchased
a few years prior
regarding Logan Paul have you seen those
flips
okay makes you forget all about it is he
wrong for
you know
teacup pig
and thought
makes you remain teacup pigs I have a
few friends this happened too and then
realizing you know wow this pig is giant
I can no longer handle this
responsibility I'm going to find a
proper place to re-home it so it has the
best life
I bet the place they're they're great
was it the proper place though but like
he thought it was they you know what I
mean right but like so he thought it was
so but I mean negligence is still a
crime right yeah like but like wouldn't
it be negligence on the people that I
guess I don't know because clearly the
people he left the pig to were not that
confident because they just left the big
but what if they convinced him deeply
that they were would he still be at
fault or would they be at fault he's got
a lot of things he got a lot of things
going on ultimately I think the it goes
back
yeah yeah he does he's busy you know
he's got the wrestling he's got Prime
pair of pigs yeah maybe he just wanted
bacon not too big awful oh my God not
too big I think it goes back to because
Logan Paul has a history of his pen and
he had to move to Puerto Rico you can't
bring that you can he researched it okay
again thank God you can bring those [__]
Puerto Rico we looked at him maybe he
didn't want to bring the pigs okay well
that's what that's the truth the Poor
Pig that poor Pig I see myself falling
victim to this Logan he's got an issue
with with his pets you know pets are
dying oh he's got a lot of you got a lot
of pets but now I I like to go back to a
video that you made recently on a
podcast episode that I did with my dear
friend Logan
and we were talking about a story that I
thought was gangster at the time oh the
coyote I said hell yeah bro that's
gangster you are a crack record I'm
really giving him bad advice yeah I do
awesome I do well so so so he's telling
me the story and at the time my dog had
just passed his dog was murdered I
bonded with him we related over that and
my hatred towards coyotes was the same
as his you know
and then you Googled baby coyotes now if
you Google baby anything really adorable
there it's going to come up a cute
animal so now you you're telling your
audience this guy's bad you know
fat man bad look at these wrong man bad
strong man bad look at these cute
coyotes but they are vicious animals
they rip apart dogs and it sounds like a
horror movie when they're killing your
dog why if you have a five pound dog and
[__] Encino you don't let them roam
you're telling me should I say shredder
never sometimes gets out and runs out
for a second what no of course not
and anytime I take them in the backyard
I'm always with them because we have a
ton of guys well you're not really
wrestling practice I don't have Prime I
don't have you're not practicing
wrestling there's a lot going on if you
have if you were also doing that stuff
you had to learn these choreographed
move my dog would have died there you go
so yeah you know I'm gonna read this in
a second and I hope I'm not bringing
another award to my friend here listen
you didn't vote for it you're here
you're defending him you're being a good
friend when it comes to the Pig and the
dog I I I could see myself falling
victim to both the pig the pig you know
it's it's it I I get it but like the
story was gangster yeah
coyote yeah I mean yeah
but he so maybe it may I I guess
Ethan's argument maybe it was a
different coyote if you just killed a
random
to be
um maybe kill all coyotes maybe that's
I'm not gonna go on record and say that
we just lost a Peta sponsor okay you
know what not even about the the the
validness of coyotes But ultimately it
was his fault not the Coyote's fault the
coyotes are going to Coyote you know
what I mean like you know they want to
eat your dog so it's their
responsibility to protect the dog it's
not the coyotes fault for being hungry
okay
Ethan that's what I lose an arguments
I'm like whatever bro and then just to
hit on the pig I think it it's less the
re-homing and the tragic uh aftermath of
that pig as poor poor babe like Pig
Precious and Beautiful for sure gorgeous
animal I guess I just uh it was the it
was the neglect I think that I bought
this pig without knowing and then yeah
for clout he used it in a bunch of
videos yeah and then you know he threw
it out like a [__] pair of dirty
socks but at least he's not at least
he's not I am the pig
I'm going to use the pig as click bait
but at least he's not saying that his
kids have cancer as clickbait you know
it could be worse so I guess I was just
in just inquiring as to if the fault
should be placed on
homing in that situation
I'm not having pigs in there no they
they you can definitely
and bring them in we looked it up man I
don't know man but but I don't know you
know what I'd have to see because it
could have just been like a shack and a
dude like uh with the [__] you know
panhandling on the street yeah he's like
yo you want this pig yeah we don't know
he says I guess before blame was
properly placed you would have to kind
of do some research on that well let's
just hear this I don't know he might not
have you why am I why did I decide yeah
you guys are getting you guys are
getting nervous he might not even one
you know well let's take a look we don't
know we don't know until now here it is
what the hell happened Award winner
amaranth oh my goodness live stream wow
that was that was intense expose his
husband that was crazy Logan Paul's pig
is actually five percent it's the lowest
one there it is so so we covered we did
all that uh
we did all that covering ground for
nothing
take that Pearl the big [__] you had
it coming bro
yeah
I have your referral she's doing better
I hope she's not with that man that was
crazy yeah that was one of the Gabbie
Hannah situation to win the amaranth one
was pretty intense as well this is Ezra
Miller guy getting off on all this stuff
or he kidnaps something I think he is in
jail I think they got him right did they
he was on the run for a while but I
think they got him yeah I guess the only
one I really followed was The Gabby
handle one so that's why I'm like so
well congrats I don't know if I
necessarily want to congratulate
amaranth but uh it had that an award was
issued
I hope that we can congratulate her on
getting out of that relationship
and congratulations to her on that yeah
and also she said he has a small dick so
finding a guy who's stacked am I right
yeah because that ain't me I'm pulling
the small dick cart every time
it doesn't matter every time it could be
a [__] horse [__] if you [__] me over
your [__] is slimy that's awesome that's
awesome yeah at 26 man goes in Gabby
Hannah's House Adriana breaks her back
21 Ezra Miller 12 and Logan Paul Pearl
the pig who had it come at five percent
only
worst award show
[Applause]
well hold on roll it I think we only
have one nominee but worst awards show
the streamies dream you finally took off
the mask let's go dream let's hope uh
Ethan Klein takes his off next oh I'm
being told this is actual this is actual
pitch I'm so sorry Ethan got it okay
podcast call her daddy
[Music]
no way so it's it's this it's uh one
it's just one
the Streamys so who won let's take a
look let's see it remember the stream is
I love you drew you're a great guy this
is a condemnation I'm never winning [__]
again though so I don't know why I'm
riding so hard
um I'm hoping to win in the future the
worst award show winner which was voted
by people who are not us
with 96.6
we have
no found it
[Laughter]
[__] are you not gonna read it all right
well let me read it so with a hundred
percent of the vote that's a blowout
actually 96.6 so there were some
write-ins apparently yeah wow the
Streamys you corrupt
freak institution you've nominated five
times
why do you hate them because they're
corrupt obviously I'm worthless because
we always live all award shows are
rigged though for the most part so does
this mean that you're also boycotting
the pcas and the Grammys and then oh I
will not I'll tell you what when the
[__] when I get an Academy Award I will
boycott them see I I know I can relate I
know how you feel I was nominated for
the barbershop show one year and we lost
to some [__] nobodies but they were
the hosts of the show so it's like they
just gave it to themselves so yeah it is
rigged I would have loved to win for
that but then I think it is honest award
so I was so excited to increase
obviously oh the document the
documentary was when they were like we
gotta give him this we can't give it to
this [__] is that a little awkward to
get an award for the eye well it was a
well-made uh piece of telling the story
I could have just dropped the video by
itself and you know that wouldn't have
done as well no if we they probably got
taken down maybe yeah potentially yeah
yeah and then I had a tweet at YouTube
again
yeah but uh they're they're scum and I
wish them the worst
love you guys okay up next is um the
greatest Redemption Arc so this is
pretty exciting right here beside me I
really like I'm surprised this was that
I'm nominated for this
yeah
um but I think we're desperate to be
honest for uh contenders yeah go ahead
and roll it please apparently more to
see one of them greatest Redemption Arc
Jeff wittick
wow that is one squashed beef my friend
so I'm happy for you bro I'm happy we
did this we splashed our beef once again
you know no we're dogs we're dogs
watching beef anymore we're just bonding
now yeah we're dogs now Bradley Martin
you gotta give it one too and do you
forgive me for comparing Jim to laser
tags
that was mainly it yeah it is bro and
then do you forgive me for um
for saying that working out is a waste
of time I do but I don't know if the
whole gym Community will okay but you
know I will I will I will represent them
I will represent the gym Community we
should we should forgive you think I
exercise
yeah Mike maylak so what I'm saying is
he's a good kid and you're gonna let him
walk
is he gonna end this thing once and for
all right darling stop I'll see your
[__] figures moving but this [__]
move on nice beautiful
I'm happy I'm happy
Hannah
Mojo have you and I ever beefed like I
don't know
that's exactly beating me that's exactly
what it has been yeah no you've never I
don't think you've ever said a bad thing
about me wait I'm sorry if it's in your
heart to squash our beef is squashed I
don't really care to touch that the eggs
family fest
I'm gonna say it I'm having fun I'm kind
of having a good time dude I'm gonna say
this [__] rules
Steve will do it so I use never meant
for us to hate each you know I feel like
no but after watching the podcast with
you guys and then you telling me that
yeah he's a pretty good guy I was like
[__] it you know make up with them yes I
messaged him I'm like hey sorry for what
I said about you and your wife which you
know uncalled for talking about anyone's
wife is of course yeah uncalled for
um it's okay bro I guess it's his thing
to you know go after people that's what
he did yeah and you know what it's hard
to explain I feel like I'm just
sometimes I just take [__] too far you
know what I mean it's just Burning
Bridges with people that you're not
really because they come out and they go
I [__] hate that guy I'm like damn
that sucks because I I'm not trying to
have like beef with them I'm glad we
made up I'm glad I won't have him
talking [__] about me now I want to talk
[__] about him well just play Just Ray I
didn't make that for laughs
[Music]
watching I love how half the Nummies are
just from that wonderful yeah yeah well
the people Ethan has forgiven award yeah
it's really no Rhyme or Reason really
it's really just about me
well the people have voted
I think it's Jeff
52.8 the winner by far
Jeff wittick
here you go brother
wow wow should I give a speech up there
yes
the people love me speech speech speech
speech speech
[Applause]
I didn't prepare anything because I
didn't um I put up a teleprompter for
you if you'd like
[Music]
I've you know what I'm just gonna go off
the books here no okay all right fair
enough you know
this is a Redemption Arc said that means
I was probably the worst piece of [__]
that was on this category but I don't
think that I was I think that I who was
but uh
who was the biggest piece of [__] who
else was it actually I guess I was yeah
okay
so going back to that time when I was
making a lot of mistakes and I had my
beef with Ethan I was sending him all
types of messages saying that you know
something bad is going to happen to you
let's just leave it at that but there
were a lot of threats that I sent Ethan
over Twitter and I never thought that I
would be standing here one day in this
studio with an award so I want to thank
the family
for this it means a lot
this was one of the biggest regrets in
my life
and I'm happy that we were able to fix
it
I will hang this up right next to my
streamy award that I won
thank you family peace and love
terrific man beautiful uh touching death
threat you know what I'm alive that's
all that matters yeah I was scared for
my life at a certain point when uh
your boy what's his name
Cody good guy yeah yeah yeah he's a good
guy we'll bring him by better to be
friends with though than enemies that's
right it feels good to squash beefs yeah
I'd be okay meeting um
meeting him now but congratulations to a
really fantastic thank you thank you for
the voters very nice all right you have
the honor of doing us the uh penultimate
award
spiciest drama here you are nice
spiciest drama all right let's take a
look let's go ahead at the our nominees
spiciest drama Logan Paul vs coffee
Zilla crypto Zoo a blockchain game that
made Millions but never worked at the
center of it we have Logan Paul himself
who has abandoned this thing coffeezilla
so your your slime is we're gonna handle
this ourselves while we continue to
build crypto zoo and I'll see you in
court live a king exposed the question
has always been do you take steroids the
answer to that is no I've always told
the truth I still tell the truth because
I lied and I misled a lot of
to support these exhaustive efforts I've
recently started taking omnitrop 5.8
milligram vials from Empower Pharmacy
eleven thousand dollars per month Kanye
goes not see now I'm a Nazi RMA but
there's a lot of things that I love
about Hitler
a lot of things the Holocaust is not
what happened let's look at the facts of
that try guys Ned exposed long time fans
of the try guys learned a shocking
update on social media Ned Fulmer is no
longer working with the try guys suffice
to say we found that Ned had engaged in
conduct Unbecoming of our team and we
knew that we could not move forward with
him cathol's first kiwi Farms kiwi Farms
has been dropped by its internet
services company after being linked to
Violent threats the internet services
company San francisco-based Cloud Fair
dropped kiwi Farms only after negative
press attention we should note Clara
sorenti recounts how online trolls
called in a fake emergency sending armed
police to her home in Canada a tactic
known as swatting over the past month
she's been targeted harassed and stalked
around the globe gambling banned on
Twitch like some of you guys need to get
educated on what addiction is how it
functions it's so stupid to see someone
promote this [__] and then say Oh but I
said don't do it as if it makes a
difference it doesn't right an update on
gambling on Twitch actually huge so
we'll be making a policy update on
October 18th you guys you guys know that
was against the whole time right I know
you're against it but then you just
still do agree to them Ethan thirsty NRA
do we have any insight into what they're
actually talking about there at the NRA
meeting that's today in Texas so much
from that building
David dobrik sued by Jeff Riddick so the
guy has a fractured face torn ligaments
in his legs shattered his skull in nine
places broke his foot and he nearly lost
an eye but after racking up some serious
hospital bills Jeff's face is Tip Top
again and he's suing David for more than
10 million bucks Slicker steals money
for gambling addiction I hope you don't
hate me on this basically
um my bank account got locked could
borrowed from and I'll pay back and
genuinely give me two months and I can
pay back the people that I done dirty
I'm I'm really sorry
[Music]
for another award there Jeff wow
I don't I'm not sure who's gonna win
that one I'm I'm on the edge of my seat
here the winner is actually kind of
shocking to me
for spiciest drama we have the winner
try guys Ned oh wow wow 4.5 that is
surprising I mean that was good I don't
know if you guys called that was pretty
good no it was definitely really really
good but a lot of this is like spicier
to me you know what I mean like oh my
God a privileged white guy at a high up
Corporation cheated no way right you
know oh I guess I guess the the special
wrinkle is it was that he was the Family
Guy oh he was like always talking about
his wife and how oh I didn't know that
yeah that's so there was a special
little Wrinkle in it yeah um number two
is Kanye at 20.8 percent liver King at
10.9 David dobrik sued by Jeff whittick
at 10.1 million that he's gonna pay in
court percent let's go
um numbers made up Ethan versus NRA at
8.4
Logan versus coffeezilla at 6.8
Schleicher steals money at five gambling
band on Twitch at five
yep kiwi Farms four there we go there's
1.6 I heard world news is on here
airworld news versus Jimmy Lee
well well that well congratulations Ned
um
Wherever You Are
we'll find you so many other good ones
though liver King selling all these
products when he's really juicing behind
closed doors well that one did really
good it was right up there and the Kanye
one was just right behind the the
cheating one but and also the guy that
um pretended to be this great guy giving
away cars smashing me up saying here's
the build deal with it figure it out
David dobrik you're referring to it's a
little I mean I don't know look I'm not
I don't know I don't think greedy I
don't want to be greedy here I got an
award I'm happy the thing is listed here
is the lawsuit yeah okay
we haven't even got he hasn't responded
yet he hasn't responded to your uh no he
only told TMZ his fault wait how long
does he have to respond he doesn't have
that long to court I don't know how it
works I've never been in this situation
before but how are you guys feeling
about the status of the lawsuit
um what do you what do you mean by that
I don't know you feeling good about like
the prospects of it
work like winning oh yeah yeah I hope
they live stream it I want to get it
live streamed like Johnny you want that
you want that try I like to keep
everything so private I don't think they
would go because it has to we both have
to go for it right I don't think so I
doubt that who decides if it's public
yeah
I think they petitioned the judge and
they have to make some cases about why
they think it should be public get to
work I think it should be there it is
that'll be spicy when that happens
hopefully they they vote on that you'll
be winning that year I guarantee it well
we'll see all right we have one category
left and my beautiful lovely gorgeous
intellectual Titan entrepreneur
innovator fashion icon
Ila Klein is here to present
the most dramatic Creator award so the
next category is the most dramatic
creator
who um I I do happen to be married to
one oh okay I'm nominated
I didn't win this last year I do not
want this one
after that yeah yeah really I think so
she's not nominated let's take a look at
the nominee I don't remember dramatic
this year
most traumatic Creator here are your
nominees
Ethan Klein
Logan Paul
Hassan biker
xqc
Aiden Ross
all right go ahead all right well the
winner
with the 49.5 percent
Ethan Klein God damn it
[Applause]
you know what I am proud of you thank
you and by the way I am taller she's
wearing like 10 inch heels I just want
to say that yeah now listen guys
um I'm just gonna own it we've been
through a lot together
um
maybe it's not even the best time
because I actually got into some drama
yesterday so maybe this seems
insensitive but it is what it is I won
the [__] teapot and I'm gonna be
pouring it out
I just can't help it I'm a I'm a menace
I'm a goblin as they say also I recently
learned that I can blame it on
Tourette's
which is which is nice because
and I just recently learned that one of
these symptoms of Tourette syndrome is
impulsivity
right and so and in essence if you are
mad at me for anything I've done you are
an ableist
[Laughter]
thank you yeah but no I okay we're
giggling
don't hit me with the Crickets or
Giggles yeah but you know what
um oh my God mixed feelings about this
one guys but it is what it is and uh
the last year's winner was Trisha I
believe right so no last year sniffing
out a Reconciliation Trisha won the
first year then Gabby and now you well
the chances of us all having tea
together is very slim but uh
you never know thank you guys thank you
so much it's such an honor and a
privilege privilege to be here and wow
thank you just choked up we got all
choked up there at the end
wow Mama
well there it is thank you Ela for
presenting that soften the below for
sure
well there it is guys uh that's
everything we we've we this is the uh
steamies and just you know so honored to
have both of you
um it's just been a real treat honor to
be here as a part of History I feel like
it was a historical night yeah
anything I said and I would like to
preemptively apologize for every comment
that I'm
nothing's up here wrestleman great I
think seriously I think we have a lot in
common
[Laughter]
all coyotes that's the one thing
probably I want to pull okay so you said
we should kill all coyotes we're walking
that path
uh everything else is said I don't
regret any of it all right there it is
and it doesn't matter because if I said
something that offended you people are
just going to clip it and put it on
Twitter anyway so it really doesn't
matter hey Twitter by my only fam
there it is uh yeah so jeffcobershop.com
yes for the best smelling if you want to
look like a b
who doesn't maybe I gotta start sending
you money for this stuff no I will I
will no no uh pay him pay me yeah that's
true all right I'll kick him back so
okay
yeah what a night we are gonna party now
we're gonna hit the app yeah yes it is
going down Thursday after party shall we
let them know we will be celebrating at
Romanian president Dave and Busters
down in Hollywood yeah where it all goes
down and tana it's been a pleasure it's
nice to uh have got to know each other a
little bit you're an angel thank you for
having me it's fun um favorite award
show all ever host the only award show
I'll ever host thank you yeah it's
awesome
congratulations to all the winners and
to everybody watching have a great night
this has been
the steamies 2022 we'll see you next
year everybody
[Applause]
[Music]